he is an American citizen so he deserves
to come back to the safety of the United
States but with that being said he's
also a deserter and so he needs to go
through all the proper channels that any
other deserter of the United States Army
would would go through the the night
prior to him leaving he was there we
went to sleep certain people are on
watch obviously and the next morning
Bowe Bergdahl was not there we had his
weapon we had his body armor we had all
of his sensitive equipment but we had no
beau Bergdahl there is no other
alternative other than he purposefully
walked away from his post it's it's it's
very rough because Bergdahl purposefully
left and so now we are we are trading
you know five upper echelon Taliban
members members of the Taliban for Bowe
Bergdahl who is a deserter I you know
it's it's very rough because I did spend
90 days immediately following his
disappearance where I spent a tremendous
amount of time and energy and members of
my platoon as well and my unit and the
rest of the army shifted just a
tremendous amount of assets to eastern
Afghanistan to to find him when he did
want to be found so it's very rough five
years later now he gets exchanged for
her five members of the Taliban when he
purposely walked away to begin this
whole process you have to think being in
Afghanistan that it's absolutely crazy
to to think that someone would purposely
walk away when we're continually getting
blown up we've been in in in small arms
fire fights numerous times and so just
to just to fathom that somebody would
purposefully walk away and no one ever
would ever seriously consider that until
it actually happened and you're just
like wow this is just remarkable that
someone willfully walked away into the
talibans hands I knew every member of my
platoon very very well you know I knew
where they came from I knew what they
did before the army what they wanted to
do after the army I knew all of their
all of their strengths and weaknesses as
any other medic does in their infantry
platoon however Bergdahl was very
hesitant about sharing any kind of
personal details so and nobody nobody
knew Bergdahl very very well and no one
knew Bergdahl as well as you might know
other people because he wouldn't share
those those details so I I did spend
many many hours in the back of em
apps running missions with him but
nobody knew Bergdahl extremely well you
know a little bit here and there but no
one knew him very very well he wouldn't
allow it he was very quiet he didn't
share too many personal details he he he
loved us to stick to himself he wasn't
best friends with any one person you
know he was little friends with people
here and there but very very quiet he he
never out spoke about too much she was
just quiet